الاليه الثلاثيه تامل بنجاح محادثات جده
في وقف شامل للنار بالسودان وسط ترحيب
دوليه بالمبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
اجتماع للجامعه العربيه على مستوى وزراء
الخارجيه ينتظر ان يشهد قرارا بعوده سوريا
الوكاله الذريه تحذر من مخاطر حول محطه
زباروجيا النوويه وسط عمليات اجلاء روسيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل الخير واهلا بكم الى
فتره اخباريه جديده من العربيه نبداها
بهذه النشره رحبت الاليه الثلاثيه التي
تضم الاتحاد الافريقي والامم المتحده
وايجاد رحبت بالمبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
لحل النزاع في السودان وقال بيانهم صادر
عن الاليه الثلاثيه انها تامل ان تسفر
المحادثات التقنيه في جده عن تفاهمات تؤدي
الى وقف شامل لاطلاق النار بما يتيح تقديم
مساعدات انسانيه عاجله للمدنيين وجددت
الاليه الثلاثيه مناشدتها لكلا الطرفين ان
يوقفها الاعمال العدائيه على الفور ويحمى
ويحميه السودان وشعبه من مزيد من العنف
وسفك الدماء ودع بيان الاليه الثلاثيه
الطرفين الى حمايه المدنيين والامتناع عن
الهجمات على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه والبنى
التحتيه المدنيه الاخرى
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للمبادره دي ان شاء الله تنجح
لانه والله ماشيين في عد تنازل يعني حكايه
السودان ماشي متدهور حكايه فظيعه شديد
الاطفال ويموتوا في المستشفيات الرجال
الناس الكبار يعني حكايه فظيعه ان شاء
الله
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يتفقوا
الوضع يتحل وعزم الزين ان شاء الله
والامور تستغل تجعل المياه لمجاريها
والناس السهوله وعملها والبلد لمن يكونوا
ان شاء الله من هنا اناشيد
والبرهان
انه يوقفه
انه الخسران هو المواطن السوداني لا
خسرانه الجيش لا خسران الدعم السريع
سعوديه ونتمنى انه يحصل خير وان شاء الله
يتفقوا البلد يرجع في سلام البلد في امان
والله البلد احط
والناس شغاله اطاله يعني
بحث رئيس الوزراء المصري مصطفى مدبولي
ووزير خارجيه بريطانيا الوضع في السودان
واشار بيان لرئاسه الوزراء المصريه الى ان
المسؤولين اعربا عن اهميه تعزيز الجهود
الدوليه الرميه للتواصل الى حل سريع يوقف
صراع المسلح ويضمن امن وسلامه الشعب
السوداني
امل في مفاوضات جده بين طرفي الصراع في
السودان القوه السياسيه والمدنيه
السودانيه ترحب بالمبادره السعوديه
الامريكيه بدايه من قوى الحريه والتغيير
التي اكدت ان المفاوضات يجب ان تكون
بنوايا صادقه وجاده من اجل انجاحها والدعم
السريع اشاد بالجهود الاقليميه والدوليه
للوصول الى وقف اطلاق نار يسهل فتح ممرات
انسانيه والجبهه الثوريه في السودان قالت
ان جهود الدولتين في المفاوضات مقدمه
ضروريه لفتح باب الحوار
اما جيش تحرير السودان فقد قال انه يجب
عدم ربط الحلول بالاتفاق الايطالي الذي
اصبح سببا مباشرا للحرب اما المتحدث باسم
العمليه السياسيه في السودان اعرب عن امله
في ان تتوصل المباحثات الى وقف كامل
لاطلاق النار يمهد لحل سياسي شامل
قال الجيش السوداني ان قوته صدت هجوما
جنته قوه الدعم السريع على قيادات قوات
الدفاع الجوي وتمكنت من قتل عدد من
العناصر المهاجمه وتدمير عربه لهم كما
اعلن بيانوا القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه مقتل قناص اجنبي بمنطقه
بحر العسكريه قالت انها لم تعثر بحوزته
على اوراق ثبوتيه لتحديد جنسيته اتهمت
القوات المسلحه في البيان نفسه قوات الدعم
السريع بنهب بنك التضامن الاسلامي وبنك
المال والاداره العامه للمرور بسوبر
هذا وتجددت للشبكاته وذوي الانفجارات في
مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وافادها مصادر وشهود عيان للعربيه
بوقوع اشتباكات في محيط القصر الجمهوري
وشارع المطار وسط تحليق لطيران الجيش فيما
ترد قوه الدعم السريع بمضادات ارضيه
وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان في سماء الخرطوم
انا لواء محمد عثمان قائد منطقه البحر
الاحمر العسكريه خلو ولايه البحر الاحمر
من عناصر الدعم السريع بعد تنفيذ خطط
محكمه على حد قوله تمكنت من خلالها قوات
الجيش من الاستيلاء على مقرات الدعم
السريع في الولايه تم الاستيلاء على كل
مهارات ومعسكرات الدعم السريع بولايه
البحر الاحمر برضو كان عمليات بتاع
التمشيط ومطارده والحمد لله ثم
التوثيق والنجاح ولايه البحر الاحمر
مناكده ثانيا وثالثا انه بتتمتع بالامن
واستقرار
وخلوق هذه الولايه من مرتزقه الدعم السريع
وهذا انعكس على الامن في الولايه بعض
الجيوب البسيطه ونحن متابعينا
وغادرين نقبض عليها في خلال هذه الايام
[موسيقى]
جسم السوق مقفول بالطبله
والحكايه قاعده ساهي يعني دايره الحم
الباب ده وامشي بيتنا في خسائر هو ابواب
بتتكسر
كل العملات تضاعت اننا هنا واصحابنا
كل ما يملكه ضاع جينا هنا المحل الحمد
الحمد لله رب العالمين احنا محلها ما
لقينا في ضرر يعني حاول ضرب الكلادين فوق
وضرب الكاميرا لبره الكاميرات كلها كسرها
وضرب الكلاب
وحاول يشرقوا الباب شرطي
الحمد لله يعني
عندنا جيراننا والله يعني دقاقين تكسرت
وناسه حنه ربنا يعوضهم ويصلح حالهم وان
شاء الله رب العالمين الى السوق لكن الحمد
لله لقيت كسروا الطبل وضربوا الابواب طلق
لكن الحمد لله صلى الله علينا يعني لو باب
ما اتفتحت
[موسيقى]
نشرت مجله المجله مسوده قرار بالجامعه
العربيه تعيد مشاركه وفوت سوريا في
اجتماعاتها وفي المنظمات التابعه لها وذلك
قبل اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه العرب اليوم في
القاهره لاتخاذ قرار في هذا الشان وحسب
المسوده فان وزراء الخارجيه العرب ابلغوا
نظيرهم السوري فيصل المقداد ضروره اتخاذ
سوريا خطوات عمليه وفعاله للتدرج نحو حل
الازمه وفق مبدا خطوه مقابل خطوه بما
ينسجم مع القرار الدولي
2254 واكدت المسوده على امن واستقرار
سوريا وعروبتها وسيادتها ووحده اراضيها
وان الحل السياسي هو السبيل الوحيد لحل
الازمه وقالت مصادر لمجله المجله انه
وزراء الخارجيه العرب رحبوا باستعداد دمشق
لتطبيق التزاماتها وفق اجتماعي جدا وعمان
[موسيقى]
دهم الجيش اللبناني مخيمات ومنازل
اللاجئين السوريين في لبنان ورمى ان هذه
المداهمات ليست جديده الا انها المره
الاولى التي يسلم فيها اللاجئين للقوات
السوريه حمله المداهمات سبقتها حمله
اعتراض لبنانيه لوجود اللاجئين لم تخلو من
شائعه عززت ضروره ترحيلهم ورغم ان اللجوء
السوري بتعبا على لبنان المنهج اقتصاديا
الا ان حل ازمه اللجوء سيبقى صعبا دون
ضمانات الدوليه
رغم الهدوء هنا الا ان مخيم بعلوله في
البقاع الغربي كان ساحه من ساحات
المداهمات التي شنها الجيش اللبناني على
اللاجئين السوريين قبل ايام
المداهمات ليست جديده لكنها المره الاولى
التي يسلم فيها لاجئون الى القوات السوريه
داخل سوريا يعني بحب انه الامم بتوقف يعني
تتصل فينا تتواصل معنا تعطينا يعني افادات
نقدر نجدد ما نعيش بخوف يعني هدول اللي
اخذوهم واحد كاسر شهرين وواحد ثلاثه اشهر
واحد عمره خمسين سنه من المخيم يعني اخذوه
على انه كافر مداهمات الجيش اللبناني
تزامنت مع حمله كراهيه متبادله على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي حملت اللاجئين مسؤوليه
الانهيار الاقتصادي لكن على ارض الواقع
بدل مشهد مختلفا لان العمال قديمه مش من
اليوم وازمتنا مش مش من وراهم
يمكن هن عم يشتغلوا وعم يفيدوا البلد وعم
في منهم ما بيطلع في منهم عم يرد قيمته
وبيحمل حاله بفل
كل شخص اليوم ما بيحمل ورقه معينه ما عنده
اوراق شرعيه بتوقف وبينحجز زيت السرقات
خاصه بهذا الوضع ان كان بطاريه السياره
يمكن كابل الكهرباء الانترنت قديش كله صار
فيه خلافته شوي
بينما اتخذت مصبح اجراءات لتنظيم وجود
اللاجئين بالتعاون مع الجيش والقوى
الامنيه انتقد رئيس اتحاد بلديات السهل في
البقاع المداهمات العشوائيه هلا رح نعمل
بيانات بالعمال الموجودين بالبلديه عم
يشتغلوا شغل ما بيقدر يشتغلوا اللبناني
وانا دعيت المصانع
والمعامل الموجوده
انه ينظموا امورهم عبر هاي الناس ويسوون
وضعهم واللي فيه يعمل له كفاله يعمل له
كفيله يظل يشتغل لانه وقف الشغل ثلاث اربع
ايام عندي بغزه هون منذ بدء ازمه اللجوء
اطلق المجتمع الدولي خطه الاستجابه للازمه
في لبنان بدعم من الامم المتحده
تهدف الى تقديم المساعدات للبنانيين كما
السوريين حاولنا التواصل مع وزاره الشؤون
الاجتماعيه لكن وزيرها هيكتور حجار رفض
اعطائه اي تعليق غنوه يتيم العربيه البقاع
فصل قصير نواصل بعده نشاط الصباح من
العربيه
نواصل معكم تقديم هذه النشره حضاره
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه من مخاطر
حول محطه
داعيه الى اتخاذ تدابير لضمان تشغيل
المحطه بشكل امن ودعا المدير العام لمنظمه
الطاقه الذريه الدوليه رفيع الجروسي الى
هذا التحذير في ضوء ما قال انها عمليات
اجلاء في بلده النادور المجاوره وذلك بامر
من الحاكم المحلي الذي عينت روسيا
هذا وهزت انفجارات اماكن عده في شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا الهجمات تمت وفقا
لوسائل اعلام الروسيه بواسطه سلسله من
الطائرات الاوكرانيه المسيره حيث تمكنت
انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه من اسقاط
واحده على الاقل فوق ميناء سيفول دون ان
تتسبب باصابات
رفض جهازه الامن الاوكراني تاكيد او نفي
الضلوع في تشجير سياره ادات الى اصابه
الكاتب القومي الروسي زخاره بربين قبل ذلك
اقر المشبه به في حادث تفجير السيارات
من الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه وفقا لما
اعلنته هيئه التحقيقات الروسيه التي اضافت
ان المشتبه به اقر بزرعه عبوه ناسفه على
الطريق الذي تسلكه السياره وفجرها عن بعد
وهرب من مكان الحادث قبل القاء القبض عليه
وكان الكاتب والسياسي الروسيه زخارا
بيليبين قد تعرض الى تفجير سيارته في
مقاطعه ميجا نوف جولد شرق موسكو ما اصفر
عن اصابته ومقتل سائقه وحملت المتحدثه
باسم الخارجيه الروسيه الولايات المتحده
والغرب مسؤوليه الهجوم وذلك عبر دعم
السلطات الاوكرانيه التي وصفتها
بالارهابيه كما نددت بصمت المنظمات
الدوليه على الحادث ووصفت الامر بغير
المقبول
الى بريطانيا حيث توج امس الملك الثالثه
رسميا ملكا للمملكه المتحده خلفا لوالدته
الملكه اليزابيث
ضخمه حضور رفيع وتتويج تاريخي
ذا المكان من اجل رؤيه او لمح او حتى
القاء التحيه على الملك تشارلز والملكه
كاملا خلال المسيرتين اللتين مرتان من هذا
الطريق الواصل بين دير واسمينيستور وقصر
العائله الملكيه البريطانيه التي يعود
تاريخها الى اكثر من الف عام حافظت على
اهميتها بين البريطانيين على الاقل بين
الغالبيه المتجمعه في هذا المكان
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى وعلى صوت ترانيم
كنيسهر وصلت افواج المدعوين وعلى اطراف
الطريق المؤدي للقصر اصطفى الالاف من
الناس لمشاهده مواكب الحرس الملكي تجول
العاصمه البريطانيه
بعضهم خيم هنا منذ ايام واخرون تفننوا
بملابس تزينها الاعلام البريطانيه فيما
ارتدى اخرون التيجان الملكيه وحملوا
الاعلام احتفالا
كان عليها ارتداء هذه البدله القديمه
انتظرت تتويج الملك فقط حتى اتمكن من
ارتدائها
ولم يقتصر الحضور على البريطانيين فقط
وانما جاء اخرون من مختلف دول العالم كان
من الملفت كثره الاستراليين بينهم
احضرت علم الاسترالي واشتريت التاج هذا من
المتجر وهو مثالي لهذا الجو الماطر
الاجواء العامه رائعه ولا اصدق عدد
الاشخاص الموجودين هنا
فحدث كهذا يستدعي هذا الكم من الحراسه
خاصه وانه تتويج غير مسبوق بالنسبه
للبريطانيين الذين لم تشهد الاغلبيه منهم
حفله تتويش على راس العرش البريطاني منذ
70 عاما
وحتى الامطار التي لم تتوقف منذ الصباح لم
تمنعهم من الحضور
الامطار لم تزعجني على الاطلاق الكل يقضي
وقتا ممتعا يعيش الملك
الاستعداد لهذا الاحتفال استغرق اسابيع
ليقدموا للبريطانيين وللعالم مراسم تتويش
ابهرت كل من شاهدها من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه
[تصفيق]
مدهش رائع تماما احببت كل دقيقه رغم اننا
كنا مبللين انه لشرف وامتياز ان نكون هنا
كانت تستحق البقاء طوال الليل في الجو
القارس
الحصول على مكان جيد والتقاط افضل الصور
ان تراه حقيقيا امامك وهو داخل العربه
ضعفا انه احتفال رائع للبلاد ان نكون خلف
ملكنا ونراه بشكل مباشر وهي فرصه واحده في
حياتنا حضرنا هنا ليله امس وشاهدنا
المراسم
خطف لويس نجل الامير ويليام واكيتا
الاضواء خلال حفل تتويج الملك حركته ابهرت
عدسات الكاميرات العالميه وتصدرت المشهد
بعفويه وبراءه خطف الامير لويس الاضواء
والقلوب خلال حفل تتويج جده الملك تشارلز
الثالث
لويس عمره خمس سنوات وهو نجل اميريويلز
ويليام وكيت مادلتان والرابع في ترتيب
ولايه العرش الامير الصغير لم يترك فرصه
خلال تتويج التاريخي من دون ان يضع بصمته
الخاصه وتحديدا من خلال تغيير تعابير وجهه
الملائكي حركات وردود فعل بريئه كسرت
تقاليد البروتوكول الملكي البريطاني
وارغمت والدته كيت على احتواء طفلها التي
اعتادت على تصرفاته تلك عند كل مناسبه
هامه وتاريخيه
[موسيقى]
محاسن حضاره العربيه
ارتدى الملك تشارلز الثالث خلال تتويجه
تاجا فريدا كان مخبئا في برج لندن منذ 70
عاما التاج الملكي ليس فريدا فقط لما
يحمله من جواهر واحجار كريمه وانما ببعضه
التاريخي التقرير التالي يرصد قصه هذا
التاج
بعد سبعين عاما داخل برج لندن خرج تاج
القديس ادوارد الى النور ووضع على راس
الملك تشارلز الثالث
لاصبح الملك البريطاني السابعه الذي يضعه
على راسه
لكن الملك لم يستطع ارتداءه لاكثر من ساعه
كونه ثقيلا جدا فوزه كيلو جرامان و230
جراما اي ما يعادل زجاجه ماء سعه لترين
التاج النادر مصنوع من الذهب عيار 22
ومرصع ب
444 جوهره وحجرا كريما بينها العقيق
والياقوت الثمين اما ارتفاعه فيصل الى 30
سنتيمترا
[موسيقى]
تم تصميم تاج الذي يعد قطعه اثريه مقدسه
للملك تشارلز الثاني عام 1661
واطلق عليه هذا الاسم لانه شبيه بالتاج
الذي حمله الملك والقديس الانجلوساكسوني
ادوارد المعترف
يبدو حقا قديما جدا يبدو من العصور الوسطى
ولكنه من القرن السابع عشر لذا فان تاج
القديس ادوارد هو محور الرموز الملكيه
التي يتم ارتدائها اثناء مراسم التتويج
وهو يشكل المرحله الاخيره من هذه المراسم
ظهور هذا التاج اليوم
وربما تاريخيه لمن شاهده علنا قبل ان يعود
الى مخباه في برج لندن بانتظار ان يخرج
مجددا لتتويج ملك بريطاني جديد
تستمر القوات الصينيه في تنفيذ مناورات
عسكريه في مضيق تايوان الامر الذي يفسره
المراقبون بانه تمهيد لهجوم قريب على
تايوان هذا الهجوم اذا تم قد يؤدي الى حرب
واسعه تنخرط فيها قوه خارجيه
مناوره بكل انواع الاسلحه تقوم بها القوات
الصينيه في محيط تايوان تصاحبها اختراقات
للمجال الجوي لتايبيه بطائرات مسيره الغرض
منها اجراء عمليات استطلاع دقيقه
الصور الجويه التي تقوم القوات الصينيه
بجمعها قد تفيدها في اي هجوم محتمل لضرب
مراكز الدفاع التايوانيه بدقه متناهيه
الهجوم على الجزيره الاسيويه الصغيره لا
يشكل فقط خطرا عليها بل على المنطقه حيث
قد تنجر بعض دول جنوب شرق اسيا التي
تتنازع مع بكين على السياده في ممر بحر
الصين الجنوبي الاستراتيجي الى الحرب بحسب
مراقبين خاصه مع الوجود العسكري الامريكي
المتزايد في المنطقه
حتى الدول البعيده عن تايوان قد تتضرر من
اي حرب محتمله بسبب الاثار السلبيه
الارتداديه على الاقتصادات الصناعيه
العالميه
الصحافه التايوانيه اشارت الى ان اي هجوم
من القوات الصينيه سيؤثر على قطاع صناعه
اشباه الموصلات الاساسيه في كل مجالات
الصناعه الامر الذي سيؤدي الى خسائر تبلغ
تريليون دولار امريكي
من الولايات المتحده تعويضا نقص بما في
ذلك اعطاء الاولويه لتسليم قطع الغيار
للاسطول الحالي من جانبها تستمر في تعزيز
دفاعاتها وعلاقاتها الاقليميه والدوليه
لتحصل على ما يمكنها من الدفاع عن نفسها
ان اسم ماسي العربيه
ختاما العناوين
الاليه الثلاثيه تامر بنجاح محادثات جده
في وقت شامل للنار بالسودان وسط ترحيب
دولي بالمبادره السعوديه الامريكيه
اجتماع لجامعه العربيه على مستوى وزراء
الخارجيه ينتظر ان يشهد قرارا بعوده سوريا
الوكاله الذريه تحذر من مخاطر حول محطه
النوويه وسط عمليات اجلاء الوصيه
ونبقى معكم مشاهدينا في نشاط الصباح من
العربيه انتظرونا بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات